hey guys this is Pete peppers with candy
crush saga tips and this is level 3 30
with some commentary tips and walk
through um 332 pain there's a lot of a
lot of hunting each bar that you scroll
down it seems like it just scroll down a
little bit and there's just another big
block of honey basically the whole level
is covered below this top part so it's
slow to get going it's hard to set up
combos you have um you know you have
these dispensers that drop things out on
the sides but all the Bears are actually
in the middle so we're going to go ahead
and play through here and talk about the
decisions that I make as I go so you
know basically what ideally what we're
trying to do is we're trying to make
combos that what we're trying to make
matches that will cause like Cascades
and combos and things to happen as they
fall so when we make a match any match
we're not gonna have a lot of choices
but we want to try to see what's going
to cause the maximum amount of movement
so you know there you have the you have
one match leading to another here we can
make a raft you know we want to look for
places wrapped plus stripes are really
good so you want to look for you know
setting up those kind of combos for
shower and we want to conserve moods so
you can see I'm taking I'm playing kind
of slow taking my time I'm not rushing
to make all my decisions and you'll see
in a little bit that this is another
combat that's great too because it'll
hit more than one bear most of the time
it didn't right there but you know most
of the time it well um there was a I'm
going to stop that for a second there
you know I had a choice between making a
striped or making
apt obviously the rap is going to be a
little bit better but you have fish and
horizontal stripes are great rap plus
raps are great i use the sparkle shell
there i use it on blue and as you can
see it filled back up at the same time
so it feels pretty fast so when it's
filled if you don't really have a good
place to use it you know using yellow be
hopeful excuse me I'm sorry using blue
will be helpful with what I went to sex
alright so now we have a color bomb
we're going to want that to slide down
you know with us there was nothing to
use it for right there I started also
sorry to say you know the dispensers you
know they're going to drop pieces down
the whole time and where that comes in
handy the most is where is when you can
get the the rat + strike combo on the
side all the way at the bottom and i
think i'll i'll point that out in a bit
here but keep that in mind using them at
the top isn't that helpful for much
so you know we get stuck a lot with the
shape of the board see there I decided
just to go ahead and use I was kind of
saving the wrapped candy hoping to make
it into a combo but it was the best move
at the time so I went ahead and did that
after thinking it through
and you really want to pay attention to
where the actual bears are because on
sometimes some of the times it can be
hard to it can be hard to hit them if
you haven't done any fish or anything
like that so remember the fish will go
toward court towards them but most of
the time I'm looking for bigger combos
that are going to cause the candies to
cascade down so you know just use of the
pay attention and you can see I kind of
held off on sparkle shell there because
there was um you know I wanted to set up
that strike close wrap and the sparkle
you know he's not going to like right
here he's not going to do that much Minh
we want to use it because we can it does
get the blue off the board and you know
but if you have if you have something
that's right there in front of you
that's going to take out a lot of honey
then you probably want to go with that
so hopefully you can tell that i am
conserving the moves as I go as best I
can that's really the key here you know
right around here is where you know you
can start to get panic to run out of
moves so definitely want to try to think
things through and now you can see I
have that what I was talking about on
the side we have the raft and the
striped over there we don't want to use
that yet if we don't have to when we
don't you know that blue match just took
out the last bear right there so this is
the most effective place this is exactly
what I was talking about and we're on
the last board right now with 14 moves
and it might not seem like anything too
dramatic happen there but that was
actually we did actually move really
fast there by taking our time and
picking our matches like some of the
times when I was making this video I
didn't even make it to the last room you
know with all my moves and I just got
here with 14 so just really want to pay
attention use a combination of sparkle
shell and our sprinkle shop sprinkles
and the specials that we can make
we only have two bears left so not
really worried about wasting one of
those color bombs just go ahead and
clear it off and that is that so I hope
this will help I know it's a tough level
I know it's frustrating and I wish there
was a you know a bigger trick but you
know the key is to really plan things
out and sort of meticulously move down
and you sprinkles to the best of your
ability to the best you know try to use
them in the best possible time and look
for those dispensers to drop your drop
your straight plus wrap down on the side
so that you can smash the honey right
away so hope this helps if you're
frustrated hope for hopefully at least
gave you a little break I know you'll
get it soon please like this video
subscribe to my channel so you can get
some more commentary videos I'm the only
one that makes these so make sure you
know which table is a check first and I
hope you beat this level and have a
great day talk to you soon